[Music]
every year millions of dolls are created
perfectly designed to bring joy to
people everywhere but what happens to
the dolls who aren't so perfect
[Music]
welcome to ugly veil friend wake up box
I've always believed the big world is
real I know I'll find the perfect kid
for me but I'm starting to wonder with
no evidence no proof what if it's not
true
find your own truth this is the way to
the big world how do we get up
[Music]
[Music]
what's perfection
absolutely people's perfect one here
break it down welcome to the Institute
of perfection where only the best will
meet their perfect human match you're an
engineer slash model my accessories will
make me different or a lawyer slash
model I'm an individual exactly like the
rest of you do you honestly think your
little band of sock puppets stands a
chance here it's probably better if you
just go back where you belong
are we really not good enough for the
big world no our flaws make us unique
those are all worth fighting for
you do know that Lou is gonna make it
super hard for you well I say bring it
on Louis
[Music]
bless their ugly little hearts get crazy
getting those
what's your name wedge head I love
literal naming isn't that right
gibberish cat
[Music]